yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby all
right brendon's getting his truck uh
worked on and uh he was supposed to be
here at 12:30 it's now 1:12 and this is
me starting the podcast on my own with
sonaz and
chin and um we are represented here the
uh the the United
Nations guys feeling good right now just
got the results of my impossible checkup
oh that's Brandon hold on hold on hold
on let's see what he has to
say hi Brandon hello bud I'm in the
truck oh yeah I know but I'm starting
the podcast so you better hurry up okay
all right you're on air you have
anything to say to the
fans all
right anyway uh he's too into his truck
what's he doing today I don't know but
but this is this is he's too into his
truck it's like you're you're souping it
up he's I he's he calls me from the shop
and I just
hear that's his tire shop you can hear
it in the back I'm like what happened
you're I got a flat and he something is
something else he's doing he's doing
something to the hubs or something or
the hub caps or whatever it is so um but
anyway back to
me they looked at my I just had this
crazy check up at a place called
Fountain life where they they scan your
entire body they look at they shoot dye
into your body so they can look at your
heart and your arteries they look at
your muscle mass your testosterone and
everything it's insane it's it's it was
created by found life it was founded by
Peter diam Manus and Tony
Robbins all right Tony Robbins wrote
this book called life force about you
know preventative medicine where you can
look at if you can catch [__] early you
can cure almost anything oh and so the
idea is to look at but before we get to
what's called Runaway velocity which is
they think in 20 years if you can stay
alive in 20 years that's the kind of
[__] I did right there if you can stay
alive in 20 years every year your alive
will be a year you live longer that's
how crazy the technolog is moving Gene
editing all kinds of crazy [__] what
prompted you to do this uh I know
somebody i' done something like this uh
before and I wanted to do for my show
best of I wanted to do something about
longevity in The Cutting Edge of
medicine and I just pitched it to them
and they were like come on down so it's
so wild and the doctors there like my
doctors he he was he was actually he
almost went to cir the solle like he's
he's he's an acrobat I know and he's got
crazy accolades out of John Hopkins
University so the doctors and the people
there live this [__] so they're really
healthy you know you go to a doctor and
the doctor looks like he's got 45% of
his body's F and you're like why are you
telling me about health dude you don't
live you don't live it that's why guys
like Norton and stuff I listen to those
guys Andy Galpin because they're jacked
scientists I want that but dude they
they break down like all the different
stats of of how people die heart disease
number one cancer number two Alzheimer's
I think is number four and they're just
different things but they can look at
everything in your body and they can
tell like so it's one thing that like
get a calcium score it's not one thing
to get your cholesterol let's see what
your arteries are actually look like
let's see the difference between hard
plaque and soft plaque all this crazy
[__] now you guys are probably wondering
what my testosterone is even though I
told you ask me for the show ask me what
my testosterone was and have I ever
taken testosterone no this is my third
test my third state-of-the-art test 970
you [__]
970 my testosterone is
970 and I've never taken anything in my
life other than I don't know food food
water sleep sunshine and you know it
chalk it up to my Sicilian Roots 970 is
very high can you tell us what the
average testosterone should be well
somebody at 56 going on
57 200 300 400 wow yeah you're not
kidding no I'm not [__] around that's
why I have so much energy that's what
I've been saying I kind of want to have
Brendan go take this test too I do too I
think he you know athletes guys have
taken a lot of hits to the head
typically that can mess with your
pituitary gland oh so head trauma can
lower your testosterone it could be a
real problem okay either way the point
is nobody should look at me because I'll
get you pregnant from here you
understand what I'm
saying Jin why are you so quiet what's
up why are you so quiet I'm just
adjusting the cameras Oh yeah oh to to
focus on me yeah just like chin what do
you think your testosterone is that I
already know oh you already know yeah he
it was low right at first it was like at
500 600 then it went to like 1,200 then
now 900 Tak it yeah I took trt I wonder
if I wonder if that now you're off it it
jump started your body back yeah so I
was off it for like three or 4 months
and it stayed steady at 900 something
but also you know drinking and not
sleeping and stuff that'll mess with
your testosterone I mean I was drinking
during the time yeah so who knows how
high my testosterone actually is good
good I mean it's good that your test is
high now I think I think yeah it's not
crazy high it's just you're not taking
it right now if you don't need it they
said just cycle off it it's it's a
different way of doing it cuz some
people say you just take it and you
always take it for the rest of your life
but they told me just in case I did you
have to take an estrogen blocker yeah
well they suggested it yeah I didn't do
it at first and then you got tits no oh
I've always had tits no I'm just K yeah
I'm just kidding but they do want you on
an astol an asol yeah a little bit of it
like twice AST inhibitor dude it's so
complicated like all the [__] that they
look at I mean I got screened for 50
different cancers wow it's because
because cuz your cells give off DNA and
they can tell what cancer cells are
giving off what DNA that's kind of
harrowing when you get I got a lot of
guys in my age who don't want to do it
they don't want to know yeah it's scary
that's nerve-wracking but you should
know because you'll get you'll get the
results and if it's at stage one or two
they can cure that [__] it's the problem
is that the reason some cancers are so
deadly is you don't know it until
there's stage four and it spread all
your body how long did all these tests
take it took four hours oh okay so it's
it's a chunk of time yeah down in Naples
it's awesome fountain life it's
expensive I I you know but it's awesome
and it's going to get to a point where
it's not expensive it's going to get to
a point where all of us when we go to
the doctor we'll get a scan in the more
than 10,000 less than 10,000 I mean I
don't know how much pay for it but you
know these things cost a lot because
their clientele is wealthy yeah right
now right now health is for the wealth I
mean for the wealthy and that's not good
yep but you can get I'm telling you dude
every time I talk to these scientists so
much of it is in your control so just
don't smoke try to sleep and don't eat
like a pig start there and you're
already 90% there like just don't eat a
lot of sugar don't drink a lot of
alcohol don't smoke starting there and
you're very good you're very good you
have a pretty clean diet yeah I guess so
I mean I I do I do I like I like uh you
know what I [__] I I'm telling you I
I'm not eating as much saturated fat
this is getting boring let's talk about
something how often do you drink now I
don't at all at all I mean I'll have a
glass of wine once a week now you're a
wine guy I know but I don't like it
anymore something happened to me I'm
sensitive you know I'm sensitive I like
I if I if I just if I've eaten too much
or I drank too much I feel it so then I
just don't feel I'm not disciplined I
just feel better when I'm not doing it
so you you'll you'll move towards you
know what feels good versus what doesn't
what about the shrooms you still do
shrooms no no no dude I did shrooms did
I tell you my story where I did shrooms
on Rogan oh yeah but I mean the little
gummies that you do like the small dose
you don't yeah you can do it it doesn't
do anything for me I me it does do
something for me but it just throws me
off kilter and I I I feel better sober
like I'm 56 I'm not going to open any
portals I went to hell on mushrooms I
went I went I was in Heaven at first I
was in the Garden of Eden I was in
Mother Earth's vagina and then I ended
up in hell cuz I took four more GRS and
you know what I learned not to do
mushrooms in that volume that's what I
learned that's the Insight I got I
didn't learn anything else too old you
know there's no secrets man everything
takes forever have you done mushrooms SN
no never no really yeah are you afraid
yes why cuz I don't want to go to a
third dimension no you have to I'm
worried I'm going to like uncover some
like childhood trauma that i' blocked
away and I just don't want to bring it
back yeah man that's that happens chin
how about you of course you've done have
you done a lot of them no Ian my friends
would have like like something like that
big and we just chew one swallow it and
then you just feel if you but if You'
never really tripped no I don't want to
trip that's the thing I fear the most I
hate tripping dude isn't that the point
to trip I mean if you take a little bit
be careful with tripping cuz I'm telling
you man I went I dissolved into the sun
in Aubrey is word wording cuz that's
what happened the sun swallowed me up
and spit me back out cuz he didn't like
the way I tast it he was like yeah and I
I was on my back in hell I could only
move my tongue it was bad was it worst
have you done like Edibles just weed
edibles I don't like that [__] either
way worse than that cuz Edibles you're
just like oh I'm F I can't feel I
thought I was dying on Edibles yeah you
you can't feel yourself breathe so
you're just sitting there like this like
ah I can't move my face I can't breathe
that sucks scary that's the worst but
you know the the rest of it is whatever
is that be yeah mushrooms are mushrooms
are like [__] different you you
you'll be there in the ground that the
carpet will start to literally melt I'm
not joking oh you don't even you oh
mushrooms I met a Genie in my in my TR I
met a genie I mean you you'll like you
look over and the ne person next to you
is in the desert and their hair is
Flowing I'm serious are you eating the
actual mushroom are you eating the
synthetic gummy no you eat the mushrooms
like you if you go through a ceremony
they gave me chocolate that was really
really high dose but man I mean I'm
talking about DMT have you ever done
DMT I smoked DMT me and Brandon did that
[__] sends you to a different dimension
for real you you go blind you you won't
see anything you'll just go and then
what happens is you just see uh like
what they call it sacred geometry you
see all these shapes and colors but that
lasts 3 minutes you want it to last
longer cuz once you learn how to ride it
once you learn how to ride that
spaceship cuz at first you're going to
be trying to control the spaceship yeah
the biggest thing about psychedelics is
don't [__] try to control anything
let it take you man that's where you can
understand like if you if you can learn
how like they've had yogis like swamis
who study meditation uh do like 50 hits
like crazy amount and within their trip
they're Lucid within their trip they
just look at you and they go they're
just witnessing themselves there's a
famous story about this Swami who took
like an ungodly amount of acid to prove
what and he and as he was an acid he he
just looked at him and he went like this
ha you can't get me dude I mean I'm
tripping but I know exactly where I am
because he was able to like separate his
mind from himself so he's able to watch
his own trip that's that's the idea
behind vant I can I can be a witness I
think they call it a sakshi I can be a
witness to my body to my to bring up
burning monk watch this [__] oh so David
halber Stan of the New York Times saw in
1963 a Vietnamese monk light himself on
fire put a monk on fire or that that's
fine let me show you this picture this
was
1963 look at that picture the burning
monk no yes I mean we we're not going to
play but no just you don't have to do
that but you can just you can see
it I mean you know um that's the famous
picture okay that changed everything see
that picture right there hold on right
there yeah okay so that guy lit himself
on fire to protest how the the
Vietnamese South Vietnamese government
was treating Buddhists and the president
of South vietnames was a guy named
Vietnam at the time in 1963 there was a
guy named DM he was a a a staunch Roman
Catholic and he was treating Buddhist
really terribly so he wrote a letter
saying please have compassion for
Buddhist and to protest it he lit
himself on fire now he didn't move from
that position David halstan and all the
other monks around him watched him die
he didn't make a sound he didn't move he
just keled over after he was dead that
dude at 65 years old had had mastered
the ability to separate himself from his
body from his mind from his emotions he
was with witnessing his own death that's
that goes that shows you that that
Buddhism [__] is real anybody can do
that is okay in my book yeah well
clearly that's that great that great
thing that that great Samurai he used to
kill everybody he'd come into your town
and he and uh you he had everybody in
the village in Japan had to have all
their all the food prepared for his men
otherwise everybody would die and you
had to leave the
town and he said I'm not leaving and he
was in a in a position like that he was
sitting and and the shun came up to him
or the you know the great shun he said
do you not know who I am I am the one
who can cut you into 100 pieces without
batting an eye and the Buddhist monk
looked back them and said and I am the
one who can be cut into 100 pieces
without batting an eye
[__]
dude what what indeed oh my God what
what about ketamine have you done that
no but it's all very similar stuff
ketamine is is I guess makes you feel
really ah I guess it's a sex drug it
kind of dilat there's therapy for it now
yeah yeah yeah but if you want to get
banged in a bath house and you don't
want it to hurt take a little well chin
nose take a little I me yeah pick a spot
on the wall oh it's the it used to be
called the gay drug I didn't know that
yeah ketamine I recently learned what a
bath house is oh thanks to that dmer
documentary so yeah that was a bath
houses where were all the rage but you
know I've been to the bath house and
turkey bring up the Haman and turkey
that's not gay that's where they just
scrub the [__] out of you giant men
giant men with mustaches take cloths and
sponges and scrubs to your body that
[__] right there and you get scrub down
but they're big and it's not men who do
that to women that's [__] it's women
who do it to women men do it to men in
Turkey in Istanbul that's ancient [__]
right there they'll shave you they do
the whole [__] thing yeah oldest
baths like a spa turkey's got it going
on yeah turkey's the best turkey's a
really great
place
yeah I see that body right there that'll
never be me you
understand do you find that attractive
no you don't care though no I care I
care yeah that's not doing it for me no
no no but have you ever dated anybody
who had a body like that no no what do
you look for a lot of muscle what do you
like what's your dream you know I like
an average dude like I don't want you to
look like a laundry bag full of meat you
know what I'm saying just like being
average you know be average yeah but but
what about muscle muscle like LeBron
James doesn't the idea of LeBron James
isn't
intriguing he's a little too muscular
yeah I don't want to feel fat next to
you he's giant yeah no he's very tall
right so you don't mind 610 no I'm 5'2 I
don't care how tall you are right so
that wouldn't bother you no yeah he's a
super athlete he's a super athlete when
I used to work locker rooms I I've been
in a locker room with this guy he has
cut you've seen him oh yeah I used to do
locker room interviews yeah yeah he's a
well he's a
0.001
percenter right I mean that guy's just a
total
freak what is he 69 260 I mean come on
look at that yeah that's what you look
like without your shirt on kind of is
actually only much smaller now that's
that's just a different kind of that's a
different athlete that's a different
kind of athlete Al
together oh wow it doesn't want to show
look at that look at you that was on
Rogan when they said take your shirt off
I was flexing there but still that's
freaking it's just not it's just not I
don't want okay dude I don't want to
look at myself anymore I'm naked it's
gross look at that guy
look at that is that deia in that photo
yeah yeah but that's yeah go go to that
picture right there yeah that was me and
Brennon back in the day right there that
was so funny you want to with this one
no no no that's me and po as pool boy
look at me I was a young man I was 26 I
never lifted weights back then not that
it makes a difference anyway
interesting look at deia he was young
when is this picture from 17 Chris looks
good
there
Jesus it's amazing everybody gets so
old just
saying all
right um
yeah what do you got Chen let's go over
some current events I don't know we're
waiting for Brendan I know I know um
let's just play with some ideas let's
see what we got okay let's see where to
start
then oh how about this this is goodz so
you guys watch that documentary on
netfli let me see this we got tag in
this so the the truth behind the new
Netflix doc you are what you eat yeah
let me see this cuz they they basically
say that being a vegan is the way to go
and this is from Santa Cruz medicinals a
guy named Brandon truth behind this new
Netflix docu series you are what you eat
and it's very frightening the new docu
series follows groups of twins and what
they do is they put one of them on a
vegan plant-based diet and the other
eats an omnivore diet which includes
meat fish eggs and dairy and they claim
is that the twin that went vegan ended
up being way healthier just way better
but here's why you should be extremely
skeptical about that conclusion who
funded this docu series well it was
mainly the vog foundation and this might
be one of the reasons that this docu
series is getting accused of extreme
bias but who are Kyle and Tracy vog the
owners of the vog foundation we know
that they are billionaires they just
bought a $21.8 million property in San
Francisco but how did Kyle make all this
money Kyle is a member of what they call
the vegan Mafia in
Valley silic Valley Elites that make a
lot of their money investing into
plant-based alternative meat companies
like Beyond beef and possible food he
also invested a major amount of money
into that 2019 game changers movie which
also promoted a vegan diet oh boy him
and his wife Tracy are vegan Advocate
she just bought an animal sanctuary in
Soma County and they give a lot of money
to these vegan companies it turns out
there's a lot of money in selling these
processed package foods and if you can
convince people that they're healthier
and sell them for a premium yeah you can
make guap on the on the Stanford side of
things right above my head right here
you can see that this funding to the
Stanford plant-based diet initiative
came from a 5-year Grant from guess what
the meat replacement company beyond meat
yeah you know the company that makes
sausages yeah they're trying to sell a
lot of these things the main claim in
the docu series is oh the cholesterol
levels went down in that group that went
vegan there are many intelligent people
that disagree with the fact that oh you
just want to lower your cholesterol as
much as possible and you should cut out
meat fish eggs and dairy to DOA and my
worry with this docu series is so many
people will be influenced to cut there
he is dense foods that we're just
talking about that dumb documentary that
vegan documentary [__] agenda let's
take a little break buddy I like making
money and watching sports and I wish
somebody could help me that's all I'm
trying to say playoffs are here buddy
the playoffs are finally here I can't
wait and our friends at draftking sports
book an official sports betting partner
the NFL playoffs is bringing you an
offer that help make the playoffs so
cool can I get bonus bets dude new
customers can bet five bucks on any game
and get 200 instantly in Bon bets Miami
Miami's playing at Kansas City Chiefs be
-2 the fish don't do well in cold
weather do well in cold weather download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app right now
use the code fighter new customers can
bet just five bucks to get 200 instantly
in bonus bets only on draftking
Sportsbook with a code Fighter the crown
is yours gambling problem call 1800
Gambler or visit ww 1800 gambler. net
New York call
8778 heny or text heny 467
7369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
888878 9777 7it ccpg dorg please play
responsibly on behalf of booill casino
and resorts in Kansas 21 plus age varies
by jurisdiction avoid an Ontario bonus
bets expire 168 hours after issuance see
dk.com terms for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources the best nuts the best
tasting nuts oh we love
they come from House of macademia and I
always have them in my pant in your
mouth it's Omega fatty acids I've never
even heard of that but I know that a lot
of people who are into longevity believe
in the fat profile in Mac dude how about
the chocolate covered the raspberry the
vanilla it's I cooked my elb in
macadamia nut oil oh you fancy bro how
about their nut bars 45% macadamia nut
bars look nice little snack head over to
partner. houseof macadamias
do sltf AK let me say it again head over
to
partner. houseof macadamias
Doc what do they get though Bud Subs
subscribe to your favorite bundle and
get free snack bars every time with 15%
off the whole order free snack bars they
are delicious all right I'm telling you
plus certain bundles come with bonus
goodies like free macademia milk and
free shipping all right change up your
macademia subscription at any stage no
strings attached pause or cancel at any
time I'm telling you you start eating
macadamia
nuts expensive anywhere else because
they're the best tasting nut I I can't
take it we know our nut we know our nuts
and uh say oh feed me grapes while feed
me Macadamia put those nuts in my mouth
put those nuts in my
mouth cuz it was it was financed by all
these these these vegan billionaires oh
wait you're telling me documentary had
an agenda yeah who had had who had
[__] uh interests in um you know in
in in impossible but you know what if
you're going to watch a documentary on
uh vegetarians you deserve it cuz you're
[__] you're a [__] just like if you're
interested in that stuff you should suck
black [__] I was just watching it why
does it have to be black why are you
watching it but why would I already your
algorithm it goes [__]
algorithm is that true cuz I'm just
watching you're like why am I why am I
getting recommended Hillary Clinton St
right isn't it weird no no no is it
weird no I'm just add I'm just why why
do I have white guilt now this is weird
dude no dude no that's what happens when
you watch a documentary on vegan
everything's systematic racism
vegetarian so if I start eating Tempe
then I'm automatically oh bro you're
posting the the thing on your
Instagram guys my cholesterol my
cholesterol is actually after eating
meat my cholesterol was kind of high but
my my Cal my plaque is not my heart
looks great so it's like cuz you got
your test back yeah I got all my test
back hey this is the first time I'm late
in 12 years not bad you're an hour late
though an hour and I got here a half
hour early so that's was a bad day bad
day for because usually you know well
you were doing your I knew I knew when
you said it oh hey when I say a problem
you know cuz I'm I can't stop messing
with my cars and trucks change out the
torque converter this sem my TRX cuz we
have plans for it to put a bigger blower
on for Magnuson so it's going to be like
1,400 a big deal so important electric
though that's cool no but um so the
torque converter the Piston the rods
we've done all this stuff and the drive
shaft I'm going down the road and I'm
like oh something's you know just when
you mess with it something's off like
something's off and then I can tell the
alignment's off so then I was like you
know what I looked the cuz I came from
the doctor dropped the f off 20 minutes
to spare no it was it was it was 10:00 I
go I can get this done 90 minutes easily
yeah pull in the guy's like we got you
it's my boy Mark he's like we got you
man we'll get you in there cool man you
dud I mean 3 hours later I I I go I go
dude I got to get going like I'm
supposed to do a show give me a drill so
then I'm doing the back tires he's doing
the front oh damn no I got F [__] on my
knees smells what the problem the the
alignment's completely off the drive
shaft was was loose it was just your
knees are stained that's weird yeah huh
on the street dude oh on the street so
you didn't want to pay but you said I
got this mouth uh yes and whatever it
takes to get this done whatever it takes
dude it's about your truck
dude you'll see it though it's worth it
you'll see it out there yeah you'll see
it well I notice the difference no no
you won't know I mean it's not you know
you you uh you need you need there's not
enough power right if they had a jet
engine in there you'd be like I mean as
long as you can keep on the ground two
jet engines that's my
mentality oh one one's cool can we get
two that's like Jim Jeff you ever hear
the difference between a ice girl and a
[__] that Jim jeffre came with said nice
girls will let you put it in their butt
on on Valentine's Day val day you know
on birthday and he goes and [__] when
you when you're when you're in there
when you're already in her butt she
wants another one in her butt she like I
can't get enough get another one in here
now always 24/7 sometimes I'll be
watching porn I'm like how's this going
to fit they always figure it out dude
they always make it work they're like
Engineers really so I was doing a little
research and I just happened to cross
like one just a impossible I guess the
guy was fairly muscular with an imp and
when he pulled his pants down it was it
was it looked like it looked like he was
carrying a a gourd of water over the
through the desert like you know if you
took a sack and you just I need this for
water fill it with pennies yeah and I
was like what the fck looks heavy
doesn't it heavy and have you been
tricked have you ever been tricked where
it's a fake one they show the body
you're looking like man that thing is
massive yeah and then when it squirts
like oh no this this is this is this is
real and he it's the kind of Dick you'd
have to hold up if you were pooing like
you can't there's no way you got I'm not
joking you you know is it's a tail yeah
some people are born with tails and
thick Tails we're not talking about like
just a wimpy Panther yeah you know I do
pretty well in this region and so I'm
like for hey for like a you know but
it's not your no it's not you're pretty
good at tennis
record I'm not shattering records no
like there's guys where that's their
thing that's their like [__] down
somebody's their thing that's their
talent like that's their thing and and
and literally then it got hard and I I
went I can't this I can't well see I go
I got to see how this ends how are we
going to figure this out I was like it's
it's engineering at the finest it's
engineering at like God was like no
we're going to make it work it's going
to fit those holes and you're like I
can't believe she took all that and
how's she not how's she still alive
where's go you think about that where's
it go how deep is it going where's it go
is it hitting her heart yeah well they
they say women have a muscle sometimes
that can I guess stop so it'll come down
at a slant and it'll stop but if you
keep going you know it'll loosen up
it'll relax but women can take so much
more you know guys are like she's never
been [__] by a guy like me it's like
you don't know what the [__] you're
talking about dude you have no idea what
history put so much more in there are
guys that see that's how I feel about
cars yeah we can do so much more in
there we can fit so much more big black
[__] in that I'm saying that's well I
have a theory on all of it which is why
do guys want to have the biggest sck
it's because if somebody does that guy's
been further down her Road he's he's
seen places you can't reach but he's not
seen it it's not like he has doesn't
matter dude men are territorial you've
hit places I haven't it's exactly why
guys climb on Everest and go to the moon
it's the same reason like when I first
started with my lightning I was like
like all right I want a 9-second
lightning and then you realize that it's
a
NeverEnding Road like a big dick is a
neverend there's no so there's somebody
always going to have a bigger dick
faster truck fter everything in life is
there's nothing you can do you can chase
that dragon and be in the whole 100
Grand into a $40,000 truck somebody's
always going to be able to make it
faster you're never going to have the
fast TR they say that about addiction
they say that about anything if if like
sacks or anything you have to keep
upping the ante cuz you stop being able
to feel you get used to the sensation
you got to Double Down drugs everything
is that way sex that's why the anything
that you chase that's a sensation you
got to understand you're a slave to it
the idea is to get command of all of it
otherwise it it never end I'm a slave to
modding cars yes yeah you love you love
can't stop w't stop you like mechanic
[__] and cars yep right Robo oil yep yep
all that oil yeah hot oil you like you
like yeah and you're like
hearing oh yeah yeah
that's right it's just not your thing
huh no I told you that my friend who's
gay who had his boyfriend and they used
to live together and there was a fine
fine gentleman I believe he was a
businessman and he used to have a
briefcase and a suit and a tie and he
had two kids and a wife kiss at the top
of the street you you tell me the story
once a week I think about it cuz I think
about it that's once a week so gay CU I
think about it so gay I just think once
a week you're like dude did I tell you
about my tell about my friend but it's
so outrageous and that's why I think
about cuz I like I like be like if I
found out you were if you were actually
on your knees i' be like I what you know
what I do I go ah people well because
people are crazy because you got your
kids and your wife and you you make a
stop off seven houses down the street
scheduled stop a schedu stop morning
it's not like a 10-minute stop and
you're on your hands and knees while
they're
they're pump and then see you then you
can go to work see you later after get
pumped then you go to work and you got
to you know he's probably a boss at work
giving people orders he had a lot of
money cuz he was living in a very
expensive neighb goes a lunch home jumps
in the hot tub watches Netflix with his
wife hey honey I'm home honey I'm home
the next morning he's like time to get
pumped time to get pumped isn't that
weird it's so disturbing and then you
got to hope the guys pumping aren't
Chatty Cathy well they are cuz I know
about it oh there you go I know all
about it I said tell me exactly where
this house is I I want to know why well
why do you want to know where the house
is
at okay dude cut that out Chen uh erase
rewind rewind dude you don't want who I
want to see pump speaking of pumping I
want to see that Bill Clinton sex tape
that Epstein dropped what yeah yeah and
prince Andrew yeah there's no no tape
okay what a tape well we knew that there
was Andrew and uh Bill Clinton just
doing his thing now they're not going to
en Richard Branson notice how Richard
Branson's in on the island and
everyone's like he he's supposed to be
out there no no he can't come back and
notice Bill Clinton's been in Mexico
since his story broke the news he hasn't
been in on United States soil he's still
in Mexico very strange dude you don't
think that these intelligence agencies
had these [__] things of course of
course and guess what's going to happen
you know what's going to happen
absolutely nothing I don't know a sex
tape so embarrassing don't you want to
see Bill Clinton pump it though no oh I
do no yeah I bet Hillary's watching in
the corner with a mask on this is
insane well I'm sure he I don't see
Prince and because he wanted uh he
wanted you know blackmail oh yeah
Richard Branson I too I guess I'll watch
a billionaire pump but I really want to
see Bill Clinton lay the pipe she had
sexual intercourse with three
high-profile men on different occasions
you think his thumbs like this while
he's doing it like he does this right
remember yep like this this yep that
former president business feel good so
embarrassing Branson's great but at his
age is it em at his age he's like
whatever all right you caught me I'm I'm
on the back nine you do what if they're
young oh well you know his thing they
have on record them going uh on record
Bill Clint go the guy goes it might be
Epstein or the Handler goes well Bill
likes him young so we don't know if that
means 19 20 21 I think that's what they
meant yeah yeah well who know who I
don't know his wife likes him young I
mean I I I don't I doubt they have
imagine the daughter I know she's like
my dad did what I knew he was killing
people but
Jesus uh pumping on tape who is this is
that the woman who said is that Ransom
yeah Sarah Ransom oh these a lot of
these women are she's involved with the
sex involved means she's the star yeah a
lot of the women are are looking there's
there a lot of lawyers going there's a
Payday here you can make a lot of money
you know but now it's out like Bill was
probably paying it so this doesn't get
out he's like you I bet with Hillary
he's like you know what babe you like
can she's like what I don't give I I
have a rather credible source that can
that I
I the prince Andrew was approached
before all this for a Payday they're
like pay money could pay us money and he
was like pay us a large amount of money
hey man your mom's the richest woman in
the world of all time and he was like No
And then that's what happened got kicked
out of the family now they they won't
let him at Din one of the reasons I he
can't come to dinner no I think a lot
one of the reasons a lot of these men
are not why a lot of this is quiet is
because a lot of these women have been
paid off yes you know there's money and
if you're the one hell yeah if dude if
you had a friend friend who's a fale
who's 40 45 wife and kids they're coming
to you like I really don't want my name
out there and the lawyer goes well what
if we were able to get $50 million like
do your thing and my name's not involved
do your thing that's right cuz these
guys are like especially the
high-profile Branson you know how rich
he is he's like yeah just make it go
away exact and have billions of dollars
50 mil I mean you and I know people with
lots of money who've made things go away
yeah that's what happens it's like
there's a problem and it's like because
it doesn't have to be true what happens
is if if if if somebody comes if there's
all they all they need is a story yes
and if you're a high-profile person you
go wait a minute here you go shut the
[__] up you know well that's the whole
Michael Jackson case like if if you look
more into it to his innocence like be
like oh but he settled it's like yeah
cuz it's cheaper of course that's why he
did it you yeah of course but the
Public's going to assume you even say it
you're already guilty to a portion of
the public and it shuts off a whole
bunch of stuff usually the clintons are
the best at getting rid of things or
people yeah why are these guys still
making videos has no one learned this is
old though this is old so they didn't
videos this is this was an island they
had like a Tickle Me Elmo in the middle
of the room and they'd be like is that
TI like sure is man it gets me in The
Vibes but there's a camera in his nose
or there's a Teddy rup skin in the room
for random reason they think EP worked
for an intelligence apparatus like mad
and CIA or whatever but either way it
was like you're going to go to an island
you're a really famous person that have
sex you got to know there are cameras
you got to know that there are people
who would love to have that leverage on
you so of course makes total sense how
about Stephen Hawkins and that [__]
yeah but that that was just cuz he was
interested in so oh what no just science
so no no Eric wion you hot chicks no no
no so so Epstein if he was working for
an intelligence agency they there's long
long cases of him talking to a lot of
scientists like Eric Weinstein why they
were interested every time you ask like
people physicist people like Eric math
questions they had military applications
so they had he had a very very long like
Rolodex of scientists I get that but
have you SE how many times Stephen
Hawkins went to the island but I think
that's just I think he couldn't have sex
when he has ALS this impossible well he
begs a differ no he couldn't your body
can't do it ready to pump
oh I need to buut protection oh it
doesn't matter doesn't matter it doesn't
matter I'm anyway I'm going to die
anyway is that crazy your worst I can't
feel anything you can feel actually with
ALS it's a terrible disease his wiener
didn't work at all any has it was that
his wiener didn't work I bet he's a good
time char so what ALS does is it it it
shuts down all your muscles it's a
terrible way to die sucks can't move
hold on ALS does not impair sexual
function H some medications can reduce
sexual desire but they can still pump it
says yeah I don't I didn't see that I
didn't see that I'm telling you Stephen
Hawkins wasn't on that you think they
made that Island handicap friendly cuz
they wanted his science info they had a
lot of no dude he was [__] everybody
who went to the island was F if you're
there more than three
times you're not going to that Island
it's a simple phone call he had parties
there there were a lot of people of
course yeah yeah if you're if I one
let's say we got an invitation 10 years
ago before all this went down well no
let's say we get there we're like damn
this is fun yeah all right you go the
same time like man everyone looks pretty
young I'm probably not going back if you
go 10 more times you're in on the gig
Stephen Hawkins was there for his brain
I don't think I think Jeffrey was into
these like 14 15y old girls but I think
most of the people that were going there
were going there cuz they were hookers
there it's like we got girls from Miami
coming in of course but then also
there's probably girls who looked older
dressed older and then Epstein would
come over like hey Bill was that funny
he's like was great he's like that was
great yeah she was 15 he's like what we
got on and we got on tape bring up bring
up prince Andrew with the girl she was
like
17 and uh there boy did he miscalculate
he did an interview on Date Line yeah
the the Royal fan was like do not say
anything he's like no I got this boy it
went bad yeah she's gorgeous she
probably told him she was 20 whatever
and there you have it
kids but he was he was single wasn't he
on the island having a good time shaking
it
up you know he was uh he was the Queen's
favorite son and then they kicked him
out of the royal family you know he's
not allowed in the in the castle yeah
yeah doesn't get invited to family
functions can't we can't have this yeah
they don't [__] around wear the military
guard for the of Windsor does not [__]
around it's been St the house of Windsor
has stood for a thousand years Megan
Markle thinks she's gonna bring that
[__] house down Megan Mark [__]
narcissist only two people not allowed
her and him yeah well narcissists will
always one of the telltale signs of a
narcissist is they they separate whoever
they're with from the from anybody close
what do she do
ruined his silly goose like he's just to
he's probably not the smartest guy and a
sweetheart she just took advantage of it
now the whole family hates him it's
terrible but that's he on him bro that's
on him that made the Warlock huh he's
he's the one that married that freaking
let's just call what is go ahead and
beep
that pretty as [__] though she's she's
cool she's cool I'm saying what if
you're Prince Harry what got her to the
dance she's my she yeah she's cool she's
a pretty girl she's not breathtaking if
you're Prince Harry get your pick of the
litter very Charming Bubba you know very
Charming actress very Charming figure
out a way you know conniving fake yeah I
get it price the neest Royal dick of in
the world yes and if you're a good guy
see I think she's
beautiful I mean you know I think she's
cool she I don't she would be my top 50
million but I feel like she would be bub
no she's great she's hot but she's not
like that's your type dude I agree she's
hot no I'm not saying she's not
attractive she's not the most gorgeous
woman in the world if you're Prince
Harry for dies like us or a couple
Schmucks Prince Harry yeah yeah but yeah
but there's something about her though
that's very accessible she's like girl
next door but beautiful you know all
that [__] she she had her own money
she's an actress you know he was own
money you think he gives a flying [__]
impressed by she was self-sufficient
they cut him off they cut him off but do
you know what his deal was I read the
book yeah cut him off he's such a cuck
cut him off he has also he has red hair
that's the first red got yeah they cut
me off and then he has a house in Monaco
that they bought him for $60 million hey
[__] off redhead dude I hate redheads
dude I hate and then you act like that
be cool bro dude be cool don't say that
and then your girl just owns you and
drive around monino and a Tesla talking
to Oprah and Ellen [__] you dude [__]
you traded that for the freaking for the
Windsor Squad dude it's pretty fun
you're driving around in Aston Martin
not yet now you're in a Tesla taking
orders from that [__] yeah wow dude he's
a good guy though funny nice
guy but I think he's just a guy who you
know it is what it is England just so
disappointed in him oh I'm half English
I can say that I'm disappointed half of
me is disappointed half of you is
disappoint half of me like whatever dude
you know what half of me is disappointed
the American side doesn't like him cuz
he has red hair we should try to get him
on
podcast yeah if he's going to be cool
he'll be cool he's cool as [__] you'd
love him you met him once let's calm
down no you you'd like him I met I
actually hung out with him twice two
days yeah it's not enough no no but for
me it's not enough to co funny self
deprecating you know just kind of a pot
he has a lot of stuff going on you he a
dude he's a dude you'd like him I
promise no dude I know let a girl
control him like that though you know
well that's he's not a dude he's not
dude no he's soft yeah you know he is is
is he in that vegan documentary you
watched no man I bet he is I bet he
changed his diet you think so like 100%
I bet she has him full vegan dude I got
to tell you I feel really amazing
growing tit I had a [__] elk Burger
today though where at One yeah no I I
got it I get it from Lazy Acres so is
that by you yeah Lazy Acres yeah [__]
an elk Burger I like me some elk was it
g pasture raised elk Del where's this at
not for you there it is oh it's in Long
Beach here hey we're lying a little bit
right you didn't You' had it this week
there's one in uh there's one in
Manhattan Beach yeah Lazy Acres I never
heard of it yeah I don't like how it's
next to Ralph though is it a nice
burger yeah Bob it's good [__] you'd
like it it's not cheap Hermosa it's an
Hermosa they're not giving it away I
mean sometimes it's expensive but if I
want some elk Burger that's well I'll go
there what we talking 30 bucks a burger
no no 40 no way cheaper way cheaper I I
don't know what elk is no you get you
get two elk burgers for you know 10
bucks or something it's pasturised It's
[__] amazing it's a great deal dude
yeah $10 for two burgers two patties you
can't get that from Burger you buy a raw
and you you cook it at home oh yeah I'm
not going [__] hey man I think you
could order an elk burger then they
Grill it no bro that's a supermarket oh
so you didn't do this today I ate it no
you're lying no I had you did not go to
the store order elk it and patties cuz I
feed my baby at home yeah and then I
cooked it this morning like a Patty oh
for breakfast you didn't make your
burger you just had the Patty yeah hey
man it's not like this is not like a
burger though I did yeah I mean I did I
ate a burer you had you had elk meat I
had a elk Patty you had elk meat I don't
like how you framed that it's a burger
bro no no it's not you had meat it comes
it says elk Burger hold on is it
prepackaged yeah oh dude why [__] stuff
dude what do you mean you mean you can't
go up to the deli and order it wait why
am I [__] now cuz I watched the
documentary and now I cocking now a bit
like w it's in the thing yeah yeah oh
dude it's in the plastic oh God doesn't
count what do you mean that's like
Beyond me dude no no bro come on El
Burger man I'm didn't you have beyond
meat remember that you you eating that
um no I never did that [__] that's
disgusting that's the most that went
away right people have learned how bad
it is for you that's still gone you
never yeah not really not like it was
though there was marketing all these
places were offering it now you don't
see it anywhere it's not good God I hope
that happens with electric cars could I
know hope it happens with electric cars
no no no that electric cars are here to
stay buob you'll be driving one not a
chance yeah you got to drive one not a
chance you know Ford shut down their
electric plant uh santis shut down their
electric PL cuz people aren't buying
them you know that do you know that's
true people aren't buying them people AR
buy people AR buy them listen you got to
SM that's a bummer right that's a bummer
listen you're going to have to make you
know how you you know how shitty you're
going to look in 10 years when people
like hey remember those people that got
booster shots and bought
Teslas we're just going to laugh at you
remember that this going to be so fun I
posted your stupid video about your fish
dude I love how you thought I didn't
have fish anymore more you're just not
into fish food that I I've never seen
anything like it in my life they're so
big they have to eat did you post the
video I see yeah so funny a lot of fish
food every morning and then I have I
have to see you weren't [__] around
your turtle's a scaredy-cat he's [__]
scaredy cat well he's never seen a phone
before so he's like oh [__] oh man your
aruanas are they don't give a [__] they
big huh how about that catfish catfish
they saw the piranas yeah the piranas
the piranas are uh they're they're but
the the Arana looks like he's taken no
[__] from anybody gangster yeah gangster
aggressive got to have a lid on cuz they
will jump right out really I've had that
happen they'll jump out jump out cuz
they in in the wild they jump they they
they'll get monkeys squirrels they like
to shoot up so you can't have food you
don't believe me chin bring up arijana
it's also known as a jumping monkey fish
I don't Tad races I don't believe that
all right go ahead we already pulled
this up
before go we can't play this but
yeah
it has a very different that's a beetle
let's just see it jump
first I'm telling they get squirrels
they they eat mice dude whoa so they eat
bugs no I'm I'm I'm telling you type in
arijana monkeys Arana squirrels no they
get they get that is crazy dude but they
don't get monkeys are they look look
best top five Arana challenges best
scene of Arana feeding huge feeding with
huge creatures there's a bunny see see
the rabbits boom who that's what I'm
dealing with here dude okay all right
I'm telling you man all right so that
food it's not enough for him feed me see
more he's like that it's like owning one
of those plants what hold on oh it's a
nightmare they're monsters and they call
the river
monkey I wonder if they act they
probably don't kill monkeys but they
they jump out and they look like r jump
they jump up and uh yeah they don't eat
monkeys but they they call them River
monkeys birds mammals and the wild birds
you there's videos of eating birds it'll
catch a bird out of the sky Bud Jesus
that's yeah dude I got I got Nets over
the top you're not playing around no if
I go I'm when I'm in I'm all in I go
what's the predators of the arijana let
me see man mhm okay they're they're
saying what they pray on for some reason
yeah bat you heard of a bat a stupid
[__] bat yeah I wish I'd feed it bats
I like bats well the fruit bat you ever
seen how big a fruit bat is they're cute
Giants I call my son a fruit they're
about the size of that dog right there
for
real that dog looks sad no he's cute
he's cool it's a mud huh yeah yeah
little mudy uh rescue dog yeah that's
important yeah
yeah
um my testosterone is
970 I told you man don't let Rogan Takin
get on trt I won't they said to me they
go these these are state-of-the-art
doctors they're like you don't need to
get on trt no you have testosterone is
crazy high I'm like I'm not [__] with
anything no dude you don't need that's
the third reading I've had that is super
high they didn't believe my first one
when I was 5502 is
1100 so yeah but I mean anything over
700 at your age isan it's good you and
TOD Filman only people I know at your
age that have high testost so funny both
you are tiny but whatever
man yeah come on man be
cool
man 600's average yeah oh that was
higher yeah that's weird cuz 3 to 600's
pretty good yeah like 600 like for if
you go to you go to like TW mid 20s
average it's pretty big
range but why would it yeah why would a
old man be lower than a 60y old I don't
know this seems like some baby back
[__] trying to get kids on trt what
is high for 20-year-old that there's too
much of a gap there
26449 playing football L was 300 so look
at that that's like I'm at I'm at I'm
high that's high yours is super high
that's also why you're ha you're losing
your hair yep high testosterone you lose
your hair yeah you can't have it all no
but it's also why my dick can cut a
diamond
that's why cat tried to scratch my dick
when it was hard and it blunted his claw
get it telling you what happened I get
it now you now here you pay pay the
piper cuz your hair is a train wreck my
hair is a train wreck and I I'm not
getting a hair
trans it'll get it'll be thick here and
then it'll be real thin here and you see
older men who have that and that doesn't
look good it look look unnatural so we
have to wait till we can clone hair okay
everybody we got to wait till we clone
hair come on let's go here because we
have a ton of time when we clone hair
guess what daddy going to do it and
we'll get look I'll be 75 with full head
hair I'm going to have that exact hair I
don't know how long I'm going to let
this go it's get when it gets wet dude
it's down to here damn I I'm starting to
look like Jim Morrison dude damn that's
the goal a big muscular Jim Morrison
yeah dude that's the goal Jon was 140
lbs I know I wish that was him why I
don't know he's awesome you like being
giant he's CIA yeah CIA plant you don't
like being a giant no dude I wish I was
built like Jim Morrison no you like
being a big old giant no I don't no no I
be you don't care that you can beat up
everybody in a room right it's nice to
have sort of but it doesn't your
testosterone it's just whatever whatever
yeah it's a good skill set to have wish
my brain was bigger yeah it doesn't I
know what you mean it's like you come in
you're like okay and now what especially
in today's age like if you get
aggressive with anyone they cancel you
so I can't use it no can't people I want
to beat up you could I feel like you
could grab somebody and squeeze them
super hard kill them sure you know what
I mean like I think you like Rogan and
Jim Brew are talking about this monkey
the tiny monkey and Rogan's like you
can't beat that up in my head I'm like
I'd beat the [__] out of that monkey
yeah you would it was a baby monkey I'm
like beat I'd grab my stupid human feet
that they have those weird human feet
and I would slam him so hard to the
concrete yes it's over dud it's over
Ran's like well he the way he'd move I
there's no chance well you are a guy who
could kill a grown man like you know you
could grow I always say that it's like
if you grabbed on to somebody I think
you could grab a lot of dudes and
squeeze them until they passed out or
kill them yeah or kill them like if you
really like and that skill set is worth
nothing if you grabbed them here and
just do that thing that you did to raap
aort you could you could have really
[__] I know like I feel like you
could really [__] somebody up that way
you could definitely break somebody's
neck super easily it's not a skill set
unless we go into Civil War that's gonna
be cool yeah well you you could pick
people up and throw them on their head
yeah that would be probably again it
does nothing for me in the business I'm
in but in the business I'm in it does
nothing but you see those streight with
you don't think it goes my head when I
walked down went I could kill everybody
yes yeah there was a Simone guy there a
little guy who was a boxer and he was
like hitting the Simone guy the Simone
guy was like B he's getting hit [__]
He's ah Jesus Christ pick the guy up
slammed him and slammed him on his
[__] head he's just like out like
this that's the end of that fight yeah
it's the end of that
dude I think when I was working on my
truck on on my
knees it was near a big garbage this
wasn't the fanciest place I'm on the
street there and the the sewage from the
garbage you know the the bottom sew
fluid I cuz I can't I have a real
sensive nose I think that's what that is
with
oil doesn't smell good it's bad it
doesn't it's like oil and trash it just
smells like yeah that's what it smells
like oil trash and trash oil trash yeah
it is is what it is dude how about the
Jews in the underground tunnels in New
York I know what was that four though he
kind of cool right yeah they they dead
but they said it's for the synagogue
when it's also like we're going to go to
the other synagogues all right you know
well no but also when they shut down
during Co which I thought churches were
open that's they that's what they said
it was used for but now they're thinking
it was something else I don't know let
the conspiracies run wild kids that's
interesting it's pretty impressive
though yeah and then they were making
their last stand there the hiic Jews
they they were here's my thing why are
they still using them
though um you don't have to do that
anymore they they they a very insulated
group look at them they're like you're
not going to let us out and they they
had their books they were holding on to
their books and reading scripture it's
one way they were being it's like it's
kind of like a symbolic not the best PR
move right
now yeah right with everything going on
I don't know underground tunnels yeah
it's it's interesting it's ironic I mean
but it's not you want to have a theory
in here what's going on there above our
like I like your covid
theory or they I think that's a front
yeah yeah I don't know man I mean it's
it's it's weird they they it went from
the synagogue to the to the center the
the Shabad Center or something which is
like all right we're secretly walking
through these tunnels you know good for
them
I guess why was there a tunnel under the
synagogue digging for months to expand
the global headquarters synagogue okay
so just to expand it oh dig in for
months yeah it just it's all of it
strange uhhuh well hiic Jews that
Community is a very insular group of
people they have their own rules laws
arrange marriages all that stuff you're
supposed to have as many children as you
can women are not allowed to use
protection oh I you got to understand so
in Thea Community when we so there's the
Old Testament and the Old Testament is
the Jewish Bible the Torah are the first
the Tor yeah Torah I think translates to
truth or something in in Hebrew um and
so so those people don't actually read
the Old Testament they read the talmud
and they follow one leader the luich
follow
uh I think it's Rabbi Kahan he's he's
they consider him the Messiah and so
they follow whatever he says how he
dresses how he who he says for you to
marry they there's no question so they
don't they don't worry about the Old
Testament they worry about his
interpretation of the Old Testament and
who this guy put up bring up lab luich
is he a good guy when I was in Israel
had pictures of him everywhere um so he
he he he is considered the second coming
by that guy right there he's considered
the second coming by his looks like Jack
Black right now yeah and uh Shabad Lich
that's the world headquarters and so he
has a massive following massive
following yeah and that's who they
consider to be the the the Messiah
interesting so what he says goes you
can't you can't debate it you like Hey
man can I get a skinnier wife right you
see the hasum with their with their um
with their hats and their the women
shave their head and they wear a wig all
this stuff the women shave their head
yes that all of that stuff is so if a
woman's having her period she's
separated from the man for 12 days or
seven days all that he can't touch her
and all that stuff and she has to bathe
in rain water it's all this weird I like
all this so far I'm a listen I'm a like
him what they're doing a lot of stuff
going on uh not in the best shape
they're not you know there's a lot of in
breathing so what happens is they have a
lot of strange Cancers and a lot of
strange genetic out they're the
ashkanazi and it started the I think the
that that hium stuff that stuff with
their way wigs that started in the 1800s
in Eastern Europe they keep it going
it's not ancient yeah and it's just a
it's just a a peculiarity of a of a of a
sect it's a it's a sect of Judaism that
they don't talk to regular Jews they
don't talk to Jew yeah just cuz you're
Jewish je if you're not yeah if you're
not Orthodox if you don't keep kosher if
you don't keep the Sabbath if you don't
do all the things they they won't touch
their stove starting I think on Friday
cuz you're not when the Sun goes down
you can't touch anything electric it's
all these the Amish kind of Friday can't
remember I think it's I think it's a
yeah I think it's Sund I think it's it's
uh two
days so but but they are they they they
follow the T mood you
know yeah Sabbath is very
important electric electonics some a lot
of candles I dig that you can't even
flick on a light switch I can't even
drive a car y sunnd down Friday and to
sun down sat if you're a teenager it
must be brutal can't see your friends
can't drive your carore can't when
you're in Israel they have they had the
Shabbat I like that old school stuff
though yeah and Shabbat there's no
there's you can't have anything cooked a
lot of times because they the stoves
don't work Sushi yeah you can do that
but it's really interesting though
because um the talmood it's like what
their leaders interpretation of the Old
Testament what he says goes that's it
you don't question anything it's like
anything else it's like the Amish it's
like it's like in some ways the Mormons
like you follow your elders follow your
elders you don't have to same with
Scientology yeah man what elron hubber
says goes follow your Scientology is a
little bit different do you CIA plant no
because it it was all about taking
personal responsibility and it was very
it's actually rather individualistic so
you as an individual have your you know
they they have your thing so all that
stuff is weird yeah I still want to know
why they had
tunnels well that's a good question only
Theory I can come up with is the
co but that's over and they're still
using the tunnels I got questions I got
questions Jim what do you
got um so there's been rumors popping up
yesterday about a boxing match between
Jorge mazal and Nate Diaz oh
interesting and that's like the opening
odds just from for the rumors damn they
no one's giv Nate DS respect minus 325
for Jorge he could lose this one still
the fans love them that's what's cool
about it I like that both of them will
make a lot of money for this I mean
these they're both yep that fight's
going down in Miami or I'm sorry Vegas
Vegas March in March yes they're both so
similar those
guys and the UFC gave the green light to
let both of them fight too because mzad
all retired but just because you retired
doesn't mean you don't have a contract
so they had to get the okay from Dana
White both that's interesting
H pretty cool pretty cool
indeed what do you think I think it'd be
cool to work that fight
mm yep all right all right if one could
be so
lucky you
know what is this now so there was a
Wall Street Journal article about Elon
Musk saying he has like a pretty bad
drug habit and then I guess this person
wrote about a specific incident in 2017
when he seemed kind of off so they're
saying he's on LSD magic mushrooms
cannabis MDMA but they're just assuming
all this maybe Insider information but
uh I'll show hater information I'll show
so then after this article came out uh
SpaceX uh posted this the actual event
on their X and I'll play parts of it for
you guys so you can see whether or not
he's kind of out of it or
not I mean we designed that thing we
design when we resigned to Dragon one uh
we had no idea what we're doing like
just oh
um and so but it worked it worked it's
tough cuz he's awkward in general that's
what they mentioned too he does have
like a speech not well maybe a little
bit of he's a little he's a little as
little asers little ASB but I mean this
one seemed a little bit more than normal
but agree yeah yeah he he also he's also
you know he has a little bit of
Asbergers when he's talking to Rogan
oneon-one or if he talked to him in
person one-onone he has a little bit
splash of the
autism in front of how many people here
so I'll give him that benefit of the
doubt with that it's cool that they
posted this after the article to show
everything so to make it seem like you
know he's actually not that bad so they
it's like an hour 13 minutes
long let's say he does Molly cocaine and
mushrooms I don't mind he's still
awesome he's still crushing he's still
awesome but they're putting that out
there what to hurt his stock I guess I
don't know he's still he could be they
hate that he does so he could get
punched in the head and get CT every day
and be smart all yeah they hate they
hate that he he's uh well he could took
over Twitter
he's vision and then remember the left
hates him cuz he took Tesla away from
California well drove him out of course
their taxes and their
[__] yeah so there's that one here's a
police Chopper that picked up someone
that had an accident and then had to
crash land because one of the rotors was
messed up and they caught out they
caught two different camera angles here
and everyone's fine though everyone I
bet he was late for his
podcast
oh [__] this brail the in the back yep
so damn crushes right there and then
there's actually footage right here
which is better oh boom that's like the
best possible that Pilot's a badass yeah
that's crazy though he landed pretty
perfectly on that road yep didn't hit a
car luckily too wow wow all right so no
so we've talking about J cose A Lot
Casey Anthony's parents took a polygraph
to try and clear their name I don't know
if you guys watched that Casey Anthony
documentary no Casey Anthony is the one
who killed her allegedly her daughter
killed her daughter remember and then
she's having another baby right that I
don't know but I watched this
documentary and went into it thinking
Casey is just a liar I can't believe I'm
going to watch this garbage at the end
of it I kind of believe her I kind of
think the dad did it why would the dad
kill the 2-year-old the whole story was
is that Casey was molested by her dad
since she was young and what Casey is
assuming is Dad was molesting the
daughter daughter woke up and found out
and was going to tell
killed her wow I uh don't believe Casey
Anthony you don't nope I think she's a
Psy I'm not familiar with this I think
she's I think she's uh she would say
anything including sell her own dad
you're dealing with a real sociopath in
my opinion well if you have the ability
to kill your 2-year-old child you have
the ability to throw your dad under the
and right after and their child was
missing and she's out partying yeah
there's a whole story to that though oh
is there that she thought in this dock
though yeah in the dock remember
documentaries all have agendas so making
a murderer you watch that their agenda
for you to question like man this guy's
probably innocent so they make part two
when you look at the real facts of that
case you're like oh oh this is a shoe
and this guy did it yeah they they do it
for a reason wait what what is it what
are they saying
here her argument was you know she woke
up from her nap dad came to her with
Casey soaking wet saying just go I'm
going to take care of this everything's
fine Casey just believed her dad and
afterward when they did the autopsy
there was no water in her l
so it's not like the little girl drowned
but why was she wet but also the dad
that molested you as a child that and
goes don't worry she's fine so you're
cool with that there that doesn't track
no I know she's your team Casey a
Anthony right now CU you watch the dock
and I get it I'm not team because
there's there's a lot of young kids that
watch the Jeffrey dmer show and were a
fan of his same thing who no yeah same
thing she was acquitted though she was
acquitted I believe can you go back to
that for a sec um go back to that page
can you can I see that Nashville man
thing I think I know that guy if you
kill kids I can't watch it oh never mind
you don't know you don't know that guy
Brian no never mind I thought I did
sorry what else you got Jen let's go
here okay so this was a man he was being
tried for battery and lost it and
attacked the judge you see it when he
attacked the judge he jumped he can jump
here's a bit here's a longer vid longer
video of it I saw saw like Mr R is there
anything you want to say on your own
behalf before I pronounce sentence I
feel that I shouldn't be like s to
prison for a second time have you looked
at your criminal history three felonies
of gross nine misdemeanor multiple DVS
got a lot going on Sir battery on a
protected person robberies attempt home
invasion trying to learn from my
mistakes I feel like I shouldn't be sent
to prison but if it's appropriate for
you then you have to do what you have to
do
but I figured that I'm in a better place
in my life I'm not doing drugs you know
I'm not out there committing crimes now
the criteria of me saying this is that
I'm a person that never stops trying to
do the right things even if it's hard
and I I did the best I could I did the
best I could it's time that he gets a
taste of something else because I just
can't with that
history yeah seems like he's really uh
seems like he's really learned from his
mistakes he's not crimes he said now
somebody's got to oh they got him away
from her okay Mr R now did anything
happen did she get a black guy or
anything he was not [__] that [__] look
how he's locked up when they bring him
back he's not he's not all there well
now he's being charged for attempted
murder yeah he's got to be put away
because he's not he has he clear you
can't what state is this in cuz
California like well yeah he's done
Nevada lock him up California New York
he'd be on the streets today he's just
not he's not in control of himself
that's a guy who's just not in control
himself not a good guy I think we be
careful with that stuff I think he's a
bad person well I'm just saying like
we're always like oh mental health I
think he's a bad there's bad apples in
the world can all talk yeah put them
away not no whatever it is whatever it
like for me I'm like you no we can't
have it we can't it's like the guy in
New York and I there's stories in La
they have eight felonies this and
domestic violence and beating their
wives and they keep letting them out and
then they one guy they were like we're
going give probation all right don't do
skinny he's like no problem let him out
he kills two people like God damn it no
there's anybody who's in criminal
justice can tell you that SC like
[__] that guy's screwed I mean and
should be yeah they put him in that
Hannibal leor history that
long oh Pat MC's gangster Pat M live on
air goes at one of the head guys at ESPN
he's like he's he's trying to sa
sabotage the show we've never got along
and then he doubled down on it at the
national championship while he was doing
his live National Championship uh show
he's like listen we love don't get
twisted we love espb we love what
they've done for us we're super grateful
he goes you know we don't like insert
the guy's name for his name goes in we
don't like him we've never got along
with him he's trying to sabotage us he
goes there's the Old Guard and the new
guard and the old heads don't like the
new heads that's all this is can I see
that clip it's so gangster wow he like
he's like watching the show than
gangster anonymously
quote but if you're going to hire Pat ma
yeah I love him one of my favorite
people of all time he's a great dude and
he's also he's a Pioneer and he's so
powerful this why he's doing it people
like you're just trying to get fired you
they're not going to let Pat go no he's
one he's probably the first with that
much power I like that he show in a tank
top a lot of times oh yeah he's great
he's a big boy for a punter yeah I mean
great punter too
yeah if it's so gangster but for ESPN
you kind of got to expect this stuff you
know what about Aon Rogers go back to
that so oh I what I tell about Aon Aon
so Jimmy went at him again then he
responded he goes listen all I was
saying to and this is my exact point he
goes because remember Jimmy was saying
he's a conspiracy guy he's this fake
news guy like everything's conspiracy
goes why are you so worried about this
thing coming out like what if it's a
conspiracy I've been right twice
apparently I'm too dumb I'm right twice
you say I'm wrong he goes I was he wases
I'm not dumb enough of course you're not
on that list you're saying I'm saying
you hope that list doesn't come out
because it would make me right not cuz
you're on the list he was I've never
said you're on the list he was I want to
be very clear you I've never said you're
on the list I'm saying you hope that
list doesn't come out because then I
would be right and I'm this weird
conspiracy guy oh God it and that was my
exact point you had it right nonetheless
Pat McAfee was like I can't have this
anymore in my show we're cutting him
from our Tuesdays here so he will no
longer be appearing on the pat MC who
won't be Aaron Rogers well that's not
very cool of Pat cuz cuz now remember I
love Pat remember Pat got big so he's on
bar stool he left there to do his own
thing got really big one of the reasons
he got big is he was paying Aaron
Rodgers and Nick Sabin to come on every
week a a seven figure salary and he goes
we did that in hopes to get bought out
by ESPN he gets bought out because the
ratings Aon brought now you don't have
eron's back
N I don't like that there maybe there's
more to it who knows or maybe Erin said
that I was like dude I'm sick of doing
this making news every time I say
something so Pat's like yeah let's goore
our separate directions but see what he
said here there will be a lot of people
who are happy with that myself included
to be honest with you McAfee said the
way it ended it got really loud and I'm
happy that he's not going to be in my
mentions going forward which is great
news damn oh end it must ended
bad I like both of them I'm Switzerland
on this I like both of them I I don't
like you don't stick by your guy but
maybe it went maybe it went South
yeah Jimmy Kimmel's kind of lost the
plot in some ways oh my God he's his
love the guy I don't know uh he's made
so many wrong moves but all good
um with Pat yeah it's that that's kind
of a bummer but he also it could be it
was great for Ray and stuff like that
but he's also like hey man this a sports
show we don't be talking about Epstein
and these this and your Jimmy Kimmel
like anybody people are just tun in for
that like you're not even breaking down
football anymore like the narrative is
this weird Epstein call log like that's
not what we want to do and aon's
probably like well I I need a rebuttal
he's like but no let's move on 's like I
don't want to move on so he's like all
right let's go separate directions could
be that people are weird you
know couple alpha
males couple alltime great in both
aspects I mean
whatever both both are doing great don't
need each other yeah that'll happen
sometimes there's only one room for one
so there's this high school kid plays
Sports he's got a really interesting
last name I mean Jesus and Robert
Griffin the third is the cas island or
we're gonna find
out sorry have you guys ever been to
Paris it's a random question but it's
not it's not a random it's a random
question I know I know
why oh the Kanye song There's a song
that's I know the song just ask a
question I can't
beat we've never been the Paris how do
you pronunciate the last name oh so this
how you pronunciate it it's NOA you say
tgaa like that what do you mean by that
see that's the key it's
K kga
now you make sure you say the K get the
a in there I know for some that might
ruin the name I don't think it ruins the
name at all I think you should get a
couple T-shirts that say
kga
please who is that guy Robert Griffin
the thir Robert Griffin the thir uh
Heisman Trophy winner I like that guy
yeah yeah he's Hit or Miss oh is he okay
yeah hit or
miss he makes everything a race thing
he's Hit or Miss that's hilarious NOA
kega all
right I mean
that's that's that's a tough
name I when when when you don't know his
name and you're reading off the list uh
Noah kija K uh is is there Noah in here
for God's
sakes that's how I can see somebody who
doesn't know any better saying it not
knowing what like that whiskey my
favorite whiskey it's it's NAA n i k Ka
a coffee whiskey you order that I love
na coffee grain it's my I love my
favorite wh me too you too yeah hell
yeah I introduced you to it dude no you
did yeah I did n Coffee CR no no buba I
I I got FAO a long time ago oh I've been
on it for a hot second you be careful
how you say it though it's a black Bart
I'm like that one which one well the
lower the coffee the coffee and he's
like coffee like with a Y just keep
going he's all ni like that's it yeah
it's a loud bar you just don't want I
don't want problems not that worried
about it yeah I don't like it it's just
uncomfortable it's
fine all righty that's all right guys CB
live January 19th 2021 come get some
that's a Friday Saturday Sunday you're
missing the fight comparing me Joe Rogan
Joey Diaz and Eddie Bravo on Saturday
yep damn what time same time as the show
seven I'm like literally could I fly
from Arizona to Texas not a chance it's
at seven Louisville comedy
club February 9 and 10 that's a Super
Bowl weekend great job Brian and then
Bricktown comedy club in tulson Oklahoma
March
89 uh the keep on trucking tour starts
in Nashville this month January 25th one
night only in Nashville Tennessee at
zany one of my favorite clubs and then
Austin Texas at the stepmother ship I'm
at the Vulcan gas theater January 26
27th two shows on the 26th two shows on
27th get your tickets now at thick
boy.com all right kids that's it sorry
for being late I haven't been late in 12
years sorry love you I'm out